are you I'm very well thank you I'm
really happy to be here you look like a
real-life baby doll I love this baby
doll baby spies yeah well you know me I
love a themed October it's pink breast
cancer awareness so I took pink full
whole new level of fully real yeah tell
me about the shoes
well these are my shoes it's Katy Perry
collections I started my own line about
two years ago and last night I got the
opportunity to be on QVC for the very
first time which is like been a dream
come true because just so it's like you
know entrepreneurship going on they're
talking to real customers having a real
connection
kind of like online shopping with a bus
friend you know so I had so much fun and
I'm really proud of my shoes and I put a
lot into them and they're very quirky
and quite personality pieces we call
them conversation starters they have a
big personality like you I love that no
no no nothing like me nothing like you
okay tonight is very important to you
you have a close connection to the cause
yeah how important it is for you to use
your influence use your celebrity for
good well I think when you have such a
big spotlight it's important to shine it
on something that pays it forward and it
gives hope and light to the world
especially when we're in a dark place
and for me it was important to be a part
of this not only because I'm really
proud of what I do with the Katy Perry
collections but also we all know people
that have been affected by breast cancer
I lost my aunt who I never really got to
knew who I never really got to know
because of breast cancer and you know I
have a friend that's in her 20s that's
already had a double mastectomy and I
have another friend that's fighting for
her life right now for kids from cancer
and so basically just cancer I know
you're gonna believe that but let's help
refine let's find a cure and whatever we
have to do I know that Fanny has been
able to donate over 55 million dollars
in over 25 years and that's helped milk
you know millions of people's lives it's
helped them to live keep living so I
love that and you're so fun and fearless
with your style what's
the next look you're going to experiment
with oh I don't know but that's what you
have to keep watching my victories my
concepts I would say for my collection I
have the Lina which is named after lena
dunham who I loved so much and they come
in a variety they're basically like cool
sneakers a little bit looking like old
Reebok sneakers but they have sequins
all over them so it's a sparkle on your
feet and hopefully makes you dance dance
dance girls night or date night perfect
shoes
girls night I mean cuz then you can put
more feet in more shoes
[Music]
[Applause]